so yesterday I told you about hurricane
Harvey I told you about hurricane
Erma approaching and I said that any
opportunity to talk about climate change
it's a good opportunity to talk about
climate change before hurricanes during
hurricanes after hurricanes always a
good time to do it by the way we've also
learned that behind hurricane Irma is
hurricane Jose and Donald Trump upon
hearing that hurricane Jose was bearing
down in the US I thought to myself
Trump's gonna try to build a wall to
keep Jose out and then try to deport him
if he does eventually make landfall bad
joke that's not like in that one
so anyway yesterday hurricanes climate
change today hurricanes and emergency
and disaster relief money FEMA is the
Federal Emergency Management Agency it's
part of Homeland Security it's there
specifically to coordinate disaster
response they're almost out of money as
a result in part of hurricane Harvey
FEMA is expected to have no money left
by Friday okay Irma is expected to be
stronger than all 2017 storms so far
combined and as of yesterday morning
FEMA had 1.01 billion dollars left this
is not a lot for them and of that only
about half about 500 million is actually
immediately available for hurricane
response to give you a sense of how
quickly a disaster will go through money
there were over two billion dollars in
the coffers of FEMA last Thursday okay
and it is now Wednesday President Donald
Trump's administration has asked
Congress for an injection of almost
eight billion dollars in additional
funds the house is voting today may have
already voted by the time you watch or
listen to this program on additional
funding for Harvey the Senate which is
expected to act this week as well is
considering whether to add a suspension
of the federal debt limit to the measure
and of course as you know these
increases to the debt limit are so
politicized and so controversial in
Washington DC that that is tying up a
lot of the time particularly this
morning getting my daily dose of
News and you had both Republicans and
Democrats talking about the debt ceiling
which is being connected with hurricane
Harvey and other hurricane relief
efforts and funding and it always
becomes a huge mess
Puerto Rico by the way is going to be
hit first by hurricane
they have almost like no no no money at
all and it's sort of odd that we don't
treat Puerto Rico the same way that we
treat other states right regardless of
Puerto Rico's official designation oh
you're not technically a state you're
still a US territory full of American
citizens but good luck with that
hurricane and in case you didn't know
Harvey and Irma aren't even the only
disasters that we're dealing with you
were looking at pictures earlier Pat of
the major fires that are happening not
only in California but in Washington
State and Oregon and Idaho ash is
falling like snow out there but but but
we should just rely on the charity of
private citizens why aren't people doing
more bake sales Pat to find the disaster
relief effort right I think
conservatives are gonna look at this and
say well they should have planned more
accordingly right because the government
agency of course they're going to run
out of money they should have taken
steps to make sure that didn't happen
but the problem is these things are hard
to predict and because of climate change
they're coming becoming more frequent as
an event and really you know this is one
of the the functions of the government
that we have to fund I mean what's the
alternative to that no bake sales going
to cut it no bake sales aren't going to
cut it GoFundMe campaigns aren't going
to cut it and you're sort of right and
at the same time we do see a double
standard with many Republicans Pat where
they say oh whoa we can't afford this
for Hurricane sandy superstorm sandy
rather up in the Northeast but as soon
as there's flooding in Missouri or
there's flooding and a hurricane in
Texas or whatever the case may be all of
a sudden then Ted Cruz is out there
explaining why it's different now FEMA
lacking money for a single hurricane
should be disturbing to all of us what
I'm more disturbed by is the cognitive
dissonance that exists number one when
it comes to when it's okay to raise the
debt ceiling or call for special session
or whatever the case may be to
requisition funds for these disasters
based on where they're located but also
you can't really say we can't
talk about climate change but we can
talk about preparedness because
preparedness relates directly to what it
is you need to prepare for and that's
connected to climate change and it's
it's I'm at the point of saying it's
immoral and it borders on criminal to
pretend like climate change doesn't have
anything to do with FEMA and natural
disasters etc and the right we'll always
say you can't tie any one event to
climate change or to fossil fuel
procurement or drilling or whatever the
case may be that may well be true but
that doesn't mean that there are not
connections complicated connections as
we talked about yesterday the video you
just finished watching was made possible
by you through the membership program
you can sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we are
viewer supported independent media you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership